by the way this this moment is really
really important this moment before I
show you my diagram and while you're
struggling to think okay
like I said triangles and they've told
you to use similar triangle so you can
see why they provided this clue because
it doesn't jump out at you unless for
example you've done hundreds of these
questions before
where are the triangles we have to
relate every single one of these
printables that's in the question okay
so the very least my diagram has to be
has to capture all of those okay so for
instance see how I need this guy in
there right the first thing I'm going to
do is draw that entire length so this
here is the height of the cone okay in
terms of getting you know the rest of
the dilates in there the other biggest
length I require is little R you see
where that is okay so I'm also going to
draw that in relation to little H it
goes across the top here can you see
what I'm doing right now I'm looking
onto the cone but not at an angle I'm
looking straight onto it okay so here's
R and this is I'm not going to label it
you'll see why in a second this is
little H yeah okay all right now I don't
have a triangle but there's an obvious
way to turn this into a triangle which
is to add a third side right now this is
the slant height over here I don't know
anything about its leg I suppose I could
find out my Pythagoras but have a look
at the question and tell me why
Pythagoras would be relevant to this
have a look what am I trying to prove
what might what things might I look for
that might suggest to me oh they want me
to use Pythagoras or Pythagoras might be
useful you might expect to find squares
or square roots neither of which are in
the result I'm supposed to get to so I'm
just going to leave that guy alone okay
and then my next question is okay well
I've got two of the Orioles so far
little R little H sorry it's were the
praying rules even I'd have to be
careful how do I fit these other ones in
well where for example is this big R I
could put it up here I could chuck it
where I I drew it the first time okay
but that's not very useful to me because
it doesn't produce any similar triangles
right but this is not the only place
that big R exists in the diagram where
else is it
because because it's the the radius of a
cylinder is constant right
so it's not just at the top of the
cylinder it's also at the bottom about
here yeah so if I put in this horizontal
line cuz again remember I'm looking onto
the cone straight on that would be
ironically big R okay that's the radius
of the current do you see it yes okay
now this is good can you see the similar
triangles now it's not complete though
because um I have measurements Missy
where's Big H where is that that would
be that would be this top half I guess
so that would make this H and now you
can see why I didn't put little H on
here because this over here will be the
difference yes so this will be little H
take away big H you good to go
okay now I will leave it as an exercise
to the reader to prove that these are
similar that's not the hard part of this
you just did the hard part
which is to look and see where on earth
are these triangles okay the rest of
this is going to fall out quite quickly
by the way we're not going to write a
bit how do you prove these are similar
what would you use what you've got for
proof to choose from for some triangles
which one you gonna do you're going to
go equiangular right you only need two
angles you've got one that's in common
right and the two the top and bottom of
a cylinder are parallel aren't they so
what you're getting are actually
corresponding angles here and here
does that make sense so tada you can do
that but you're a few lines to actually
include that because they've said use
similar triangles so that's part of the
proof but once you have done that after
your four or five lines of proof for
done where do we go now okay well you
can see that I've got a little triangle
and a big triangle right and so I can
compare those sites to the between each
other right so for example if I look at
this little triangle here this is the
vertical side and it corresponds to in
the bigger triangle which length this is
the little one vertical side it
corresponds to a little H doesn't it
this whole length T which you can see
right there okay so that's the side it
corresponds to
in the horizontal plane you can see I've
got this is the small triangle that's
the big one so is that okay
all right this is a proof now you tell
me what to do what direction should I go
in to get to the desired result have a
look they give you the the final ending
they want the way you would say it is
you want to make what the subject bah
okay so you see it's entangled with all
of this stuff over here so what would
you like me to do in order to get what
what's the first thing you'd like me to
get rid of well talk about H let's get
rid of this fraction that's fine so H
take away H gives me H on O so if I so
good now what okay I'm going to do some
addition and subtraction so it seems to
me like if I add capital H to both sides
it would appear here but of course I
don't want it with this guy so I might
have to subtract this simultaneously so
that leaves me with this how does that
look okay now immediately I know I'm
heading in the right direction because
look remember we always have one eye on
our working and one eye on our
destination you're like look I've got
little R on the denominator this looks
good doesn't it I'm pretty much there
what would I do on the next line
remember that final line that's there
you get nothing for that right
everything is about what's before so
let's skip anything what's my next line
yeah so this guy here I wanted to talk
to this fraction so I'm gonna write that
as little H little R and now I can
combine right so like so that look okay
and now I just have to factorize but
this line here really is um it's a bit
of a nothing because it was given okay
so you're happy that make sense now like
I said before if I wanted to make this
question harder I would expect you to
work out hmm
I have two variables I have to get one
in terms of the other what can I use to
combine these get one out of the way
okay so now I've done that have a look
at Part B read it and tell me what I
need to do
I need an expression right it says
whoops my screen is disappeared
help if I open the right window today
there we go
it says find an expression for the
volume of the cylinder in terms of the
variable capital R now I just got this
capital H in terms of capital R so when
I say volume of a sphere the first side
of a cylinder
the first way I would do it is just to
quote the formula right what is it 1/3
remember sorry this is a cone there's no
third this is just a cylinder
it's just PI by hi be careful which are
it's bigger it's bigger have a look this
is what I have a diagram here yes ok PI
big R squared and big H yes ok now this
is a this is this is the way you'd
actually write this maybe put this on
the side this is a function in two
variables so this is V as a function of
R and H it's not a function of Pi
because pi is just the number right but
at the moment there are two variables
and I need to change that so I can get
working to work with derivatives for any
who one who's curious I in university
level maths we talk about functions like
this and we talked about when you can't
do this trick and you're stuck with more
than one variable sometimes you're stuck
at several and you have to differentiate
with respect to one of the variables
only we call these partial derivatives
so that's something which is reserved
for those particular people who were
masochistic enough to study that's it
you knew okay we're gonna fix this H is
this there it is so I'm gonna write this
is PI R squared times that let's see
here ah is there anything I can
particularly do to make this any simple
nothing jumps out at me in particular I
could I could expand some stuff I could
combine it into one fraction but I don't
think there's any special gain in it's
not like any terms of really gonna
cancel out and that's because of
remember we said before all these
printing rules flying around they're
constants but they make it hard they
don't simplify out so I'm sort of done
that is an expression for the volume of
the cylinder in terms of the variable ah
it's got a whole lot of other things
there like pi but they're just numbers
right there just constants so I don't
need to worry about them